a promotional video made
three years ago
[Music]
on her own youtube channel displaying
her passion
her drive for equality
within months of this being filmed the
young saudi activist was in jail
and she's been there ever since she
hasn't been convicted of anything
her trial now in a terror court only
began today
my sister is really not healthy her
sister lena
is now her voice and described her state
the last time their parents were allowed
to see her
she was on a hunger strike only to be
able to see my parents or talk to them
her body was really shaking and her
voice was very low
there are no images from the trial no
details it is effectively secret
so what's the evidence against her well
last month the saudi minister for
foreign affairs told us
we won't find out until the trial is
over has to do with
national security it has to do with
taking funds from foreign powers and
giving them to hostile powers it has to
do with trying to recruit people in
sensitive position in order to
obtain sensitive documents and give them
to powers hostile to the kingdom of
saudi arabia
but the family says the charge sheet
relating to her case makes no
specific reference to any of these
issues
at the heart of her ordeal are the most
horrific allegations of torture
and sexual assault they would waterboard
her they would flog her
beat her sexually harass her
this doesn't look good for saudi arabia
does it this is a woman's
right to female rights activist our
security officials
dispute that in terms of normal contact
and in terms of hunger strike and in
terms of abuse and in terms of
this issue was taken very seriously by
the leadership of my country
and his majesty and the crown prince
ordered an investigation into the issue
the allegations of abuse of torture
and so on what basis do people say this
we
as far as i know this is not correct the
irony of course is that by imprisoning
her
the saudi authorities have simply raised
her profile
and that of the cause she represents
the country may on the surface be trying
to present itself as reformed
a place where women can now drive where
religious police have gone
where tourists are encouraged to come
the host of this year's g20 no less
the reality say her family is very
different
my message to the international
community is that
i think there is more research to do
about what saudi arabia
is really inside of the country and that
they have to be aware that
now there are two saudi arabias the
saudi arabia the west seas and the saudi
arabia
saudi people live under the family says
it is lujan's strength and determination
which carries them through this
they have no idea how long the trial
will last or when they will next see her
mark stone sky news